welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host did a definition aka the guy
that always wants to get nuts K peanuts
available at all good grocery stores now
speaking of getting nuts
DC have been knocking it out of the park
recently with their announcements in the
last week they've dropped a ton of new
updates and it really is an incredible
time to be a comic book fan because of
them Thank You DC Hale Snyder oh now
there's a ton of information to talk
about and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down all of the
latest updates from the company
including the Michael King casting news
what it means for the flash the upcoming
Suicide Squad game rumors Snyder
katralla an announcement Catwoman
catsuit and everything else that's been
dropped in the last week there's gonna
be full spoilers here in regards to
potential plots reveals and more so if
you don't anything rune then I highly
recommend that you turn off now please
drop a thumbs up if you're a die-hard DC
fan and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this let's get into the stories okay so
firstly I think we should start off with
a thing that pretty much broke the
internet last week that is the Snyder
cut trailer this little teaser contained
a full scene from the film in which
Diana went on a discovery for who
Darkseid really was now from what we
know about the Snyder cut this scene
takes place at the end of the movie and
acts as a sort of epilogue to the events
of the film in the climax of the finale
Diana actually behead Steppenwolf as he
beheads into the boom tube and through
it the heroes of Earth can see Darkseid
on the other end
he stops Steppenwolf's head with his
boot and shows that he's really not
messing a boot that that's if you're
Canadian for everyone else it's about
and I'll stop doing the jokes now now
Diana believes that she knows who the
character is as in a story on the old
war she describes how the charge was led
by dark side and not Steppenwolf and
this glance at the character makes her
go and look for him this is where she
discovers an ancient mural with the
villain on and this scene actually
a lot of things to impact from it in the
mural we can see a spear on the left
hand side and it also seems like
Darkseid is holding this and the crappy
480p shot of him at the end of the
trailer this may be the spear of destiny
which is a DC Comics MacGuffin that's
been used in several storylines it
definitely seems like the kind of thing
that Darkseid would have and yeah I
really hope that it is in the center is
what looks like a crystal and now I have
seen some say that this is the Kaos
crystal from the comics I actually
disagree with that and I think that it
simply might just be three mother boxes
coming together to form the unity it
does look like three cubes existing in
the same place at the same time to me so
that's what I personally think it is
behind Diana we can also see three cubes
in the wall which are the mother boxes
and thus I think this is a safe
assumption to make Jesse Eisenberg
narrates the trailer with his speech
from the ending of Batman V Superman and
in it he says the bells been rung which
means that Darkseid's forces are coming
for earth Darkseid is likely on his way
and then we get the shot of him from the
prologue of the Schneider cut attacking
earth so yeah even though it's a very
short trailer there's still a lot to
impac from it and this already feels
like it's better than the Whedon cut and
you know why it was probably the best 30
seconds of 2020 in addition to this we
also learned a couple more aspects of
the Snyder verse including who was going
to take up the mantle of Robin now we
have known for some time that it was
indeed Dick Grayson that was shown as
the one that Joker murdered in BBS in
the intro of the movie one of the graves
actually belongs to dick and thus we can
close the book on him appearing in the
DCE you unless they lazarus pit him or
something again but that's more Jason
tada
and anyway look I'm getting sidetracked
when asked which Robin the DC EU was
gone to center around Snyder actually
came out on his Bureau and said that
Kerry Kelley was going to be the focus
going forward now while she was not
supposed to be a character in the Snyder
cut it is possible with the additional
scenes and reshoots that they might
start to slowly sell the seeds of her
appearance into the movie and who knows
with the cup being released on HBO max
we might start to head towards the
originally intended
for the universe speaking of originals
it looks like we might also be getting a
return of Michael Keaton as The Dark
Knight yesterday the story broke that
the actor had been in talks to a price
his role in the upcoming flash movie now
I did say that I believe that this was
going to be Thomas Wayne as the flash
film has always been labeled as a
flashpoint movie however more rumors
have emerged since last night on exactly
what his role entails according to the
new leaks flash will time-travel to the
day his mother died and save her from a
fate however this will have a butterfly
effect that will cause several things to
shift including when Bruce was born and
therefore when Batman was created in the
comics upon returning to the present
flash found Thomas Wayne however
apparently DC are taking things in
another direction upon getting back to
the future
flash will find a much older Batman
namely Keaton who will be replacing
Affleck Keaton will reportedly appear
across multiple movies similar to Nick
Fury and he will act more as a mentor
figure than going out and punching
people in the face but a1 is still
see'em punch people in the face
anyway Batman in Batman Returns will
become canon and Bruce will also be
mentoring Batgirl the Pattinson version
will be a standalone universe but I'm
actually hoping that they do something
special with it now this is just me
praying for the best case scenario but I
really hope that the Returns rumors
being canon are false and instead
Pattinson is just a younger version of
the character that existed in the 90s
and therefore was also knocking about
roughly at the same time that phoenixes
joker was I doubt that that will happen
but yeah I would love it and the whole
timeline being changed definitely makes
it a possibility now upon learning this
we also heard that Jeffrey Dean Morgan
would now no longer be playing Thomas
Wayne instead Bruce is going to be
taking center stage but I must stress
though that none of this is confirmed
and though I have seen people jumping on
the the Keaton will be Bruce bandwagon
absolutely nowhere has this been set for
definite and he could even end up being
Thomas as we suggested now again no one
knows for definite at this
and including me and no matter how many
people say is confirmed is coming back
the reports just state that he's in
talks in talks normally means that they
have ideas but I'm sure if Keaton wanted
to try something different a studio
would be down for it now what this does
is that it introduces the multiverse of
the DCE you land in which all versions
of Batman can exist across multiple
realities so theoretically there's a
world where you yes you you are actually
Batman
so yeah sorry about your parents but
congratulations now I am very hyped over
this and if it turns out to be true it's
gonna be a game-changer for DC who could
end up entering the 20s with a lineup
that could easily best marvel I do think
that this was initially going to be a
big announcement at DC fandom but then
the news leaked and and the internet
just run with it obviously we're hyped
over here and I can't wait to see how
this story develops now though yesterday
was filled with some great news some sad
news also came with the passing of Joel
Schumacher Schumacher directed both
Batman Forever and Batman and Robin and
now they're often said to be bad movies
I actually do find a lot of fun in them
I mean who doesn't love those ice puns I
know I for one definitely can just sit
through Batman and Robin and have a
great time Schumacher will probably be
remembered for those films the most but
he also made some absolute critical
classics such as The Lost Boys and
falling-down both of which are brilliant
Schumacher sadly passed away at 80 but
he leaves behind a long enriched legacy
that will definitely be remembered rest
in peace now with all of this news about
Keaton in the flash Pattinson film has
been overshadowed slightly but you
definitely shouldn't overlook it and we
have a new interview with zoe kravitz
that teases how a catsuit will be when
discussing it she said it's funny I
really didn't think about how difficult
it is to make something like a catsuit
original like how do you reinvent the
jean jacket you know but Jacqueline
Duran our everything costume designer is
just a genius it was cool to be part of
the process because sometimes with films
this big it can be very much
son stand over there say this and Matt
Reeves is very much about the process
the whole thing designing the suit began
with conversations between me Matt and
Jaclyn we kind of bird this thing
together and there are references the
year of comics were dealing with it's
cool if this card pandemic lockdown
hadn't happened it would have already
come out by now I love it so it's kind
of bittersweet and though we do have
more of an idea of what it looks like it
sucks that we could have seen it by now
if it had not been for the pandemic as
we've said in our other Batman videos
it's clear that Reeves has taken the
idea of how the movie is gonna look
across the board and applied it to every
facet of the design thus the DIY nature
of the Batsuit lines up with the
Batmobile and this is clearly reflected
in Kravitz's costume she also said the
following in regards to Patton sins
betrayal and her reading material oh it
was amazing he's Batman when he's
wearing the costume he's Batman it's
interesting you really don't get used to
seeing Batman walk past you we've all
grown up with this character so it's
like a pinch me moment all the time he's
wonderful
he's really wonderful I've been reading
the year 1 comic it's wonderful it's
great it's great it's like super badass
it is it's badass so yeah it sounds
wonderful
it sounds great its own super badass now
Catwoman of course played a big part in
year 1 and it does seem like they're
sort of leaning towards that
characterization as even the short head
Selina is similar to how she currently
looks at the moment so I do think it's
safe to say that they will be heading in
that direction and it's not something
that we've really seen on film before
sure we've had facets of it but it seems
like they're really leaning into it and
finally is the room and that Rock
Steady's next DC game will be a Suicide
Squad title on reset era fans noticed
that the Arkham series developer had
registered the following domains Suicide
Squad killer Justice League comm Suicide
Squad gang comm and Gotham Knights gang
comm this brings a lot with it and
according to high Beast comm WB Montreal
are working on the Gotham Knights game
whilst Rocksteady handle the Suicide
Squad one the squad were teased at the
end of our Cameron's and if one of those
don't
as an indicator of what could be
happening in the game it seems like you
may be fighting the Justice League you
might even be killing the Justice League
you might be a character called WB and
you might have to kill Joss Whedon's
version of the Justice League get having
that now I think this would provide some
absolutely incredible boss fights and I
really hope that's a direction they take
Gotham Knights is meant to center around
the core of owls which is slowly being
teased by WB and it would make an
incredible foe for the city anyway I'm
so excited to see what the reveals are
at DC fandom it sounds like it's just
gonna be an incredible day now that's
all of the updates out the way and I'm
surprised I managed to fit them all into
one video and do such a bloody good job
of breaking them all down as well I'm
alright now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the news so make sure
you comment below and let me know and if
you enjoyed this video then please drop
a thumbs up but make sure you check out
our breakdown of the Keaton story and
some fake pot leaks that we need to
clear up which is gonna be linked at the
end you want to support the channel from
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early gonna come chat to us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
or click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this
multi-kill when the MCU infinitely saga
box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on the more
videos you comment on the more you have
a chance of winning so make sure you get
involved the one it's gonna be chosen at
random on the 15th of July and the cell
be shipped out from name to ever gets
the prize so best of luck to everyone
who takes part Cheers
[Music]
[Music]